but in a country of 330 million the
federal government does not have the
capacity for policing something so large
and so vast i mean look if it really
came down to the fact that people were
losing came down to the people losing
confidence in the government alaska
would not be part of this country
anymore yeah it's just too far away yeah
and it'd be difficult it would just
become something different i mean look
at the collapse of the roman empire well
different countries emerge from it well
we're talking about alaska it's arguably
not as beautiful as new zealand but you
can still homestead there i was um out
in nome alaska two years ago and now if
you can get waterfront ocean property as
long as you do i think some minimal
upgrade every year you can have your own
plot of land out there now a can of
pringles back then you know three years
ago would cost you about nine dollars so
it's probably 50 today yeah somebody
numb can back me up but yeah this home
setting is still a real thing where you
can but winter plan
but winter then
right people in the comment section are
saying the woking dead
i love the comment section so much i
seriously
[Music]
i mean hawaii i don't think can hawaii
sustain its population without importing
i
it's the fracture of the empire when you
see hawaii ago i lived in guam for four
years right guam you know u.s territory
right i live there for your station out
there and uh that's where jack and i
were the same unit out there and and
yeah it's uh out there i mean yeah it
does really well to sustain like the
local population but everything that's
there i mean if it just everything
devolved i mean the upside is there's
fresh water there and but as far as like
the food you run out of food real quick
i was reading that on a lot of these
islands in the pacific yeah there's too
many people now and so all of the human
waste is contaminating the water around
the the islands it's contaminating the
ground water so that's where they get
their water to drink
and so then people run out into the
ocean to do their business and now it's
contaminating everything else like
there's a limit to many people you've
got to pull it out like at least i mean
the regulation grows like for the for
most ships merchant ships or even like
navy ships whatever it's like two and a
half miles i think you'll be two and a
half mile to pump it out which really is
because i mean you know all the fish
poop there too you know so
you know but that's why but if you're
just out in the beach you know you're
running out there just waiting out there
to go yeah that's different story that's
bad the funniest thing was instead of
you know pumping it ways away you could
pump it in port as long as you paid the
host country yeah so you could pump it
onto another ship like a poop ship yeah
but the funniest thing was seeing the
poop ship just have the pipe go across
the ship onto the other side and then
they pump it into their own port and
you're paying them for every gallon
yeah like some countries they'll just
let you pump over the side like in their
like spain surprisingly spain like we're
like what do we do for like our sewage
service while we're important like just
pump inside
do you guys remember that story where
dave matthews band went over the bridge
in chicago and the bus driver hit the
release and it sprayed a boat going
under the bridge
tour bus i think that's what it was
right it was dave matthews band that's
because the the bridges in chicago are
like greats
so as the bus went over i guess the
driver was like no i'll notice it's
going in the river and there was a there
was a boat underneath and they all got
sprayed
as a proud trailer park uh enthusiast
black water is not fun uh oh
yeah it's gross people don't understand
they don't get it they think rv life is
glorious and you're going to be like
those instagram babes
i mean
no one asked the question whenever i see
one of these instagram babes or like uh
youtube people van life people i'm like
where do you poop
because you're making it look all
glorious and nice but show us the real
footage of you cleaning out the black
tank show us the reality of what happens
when you gotta go uh that's the reality
that people are denied seeing a lot of
the times because it's glorified you
think about that when i watch tv a lot
all the characters on tv like matt damon
like when does his character poop how
come we don't see that on the movie i
don't know every day in the movie he's
doing it probably almost do you want to
see that on the movie i want realism
give it to me there's nothing you're
what you're watching you born ultimatum
and then he's like hey give me a second
i gotta take a dump yeah i'm just
watching he's terrible he goes in the
stall and he sits down
and then he gets up and he's washing his
hands and he just shows all of it he's
brushing his head that's the move that
ian wants yeah
hold on we were talking about the
federal government's abilities did we
get to reduce waste and then we talked
about these islands and potentially
breaking away i'm thinking about
cannibalism did we segway
we did i've been thinking a lot about
cannibalism as we've been talking about
this like what are they going to the
city eat rats and then what eat each
other and then like these the zombie
hordes in like the walking dead they
don't show is the hordes eating each
other because they're zombies in the
show but they're actually if they're
starving humans they're just gonna start
eating each other but you're gonna get
an instagram video of someone like
picking a human court like eating
and that's when you know really that's
going to be the iconic but
yes but what if these soy boys start
eating that much meat wouldn't that
boost their testosterone oh yeah and
then all of a sudden they'd be like they
turn into you know much more aggressive
prionic but if they're vegetarian to
begin with can they just start eating
they get the shakes i think if you eat
meat something bad happens right that's
right that's right yeah yeah you get it
it'll mess you up you guys ever see the
book of eli
yeah that movie is great but they do
this thing where they'll be like show me
your hands and you have to hold your
hands up and the people who are
cannibals they shake from uh parent
disease yeah right yeah prions it's like
a protein fold i think in the beginning
yeah let me know so you get the shakes
from from cannibalism
so if you can't hold your hands straight
then they're like ah they you know get
him and then i think he actually goes to
a place where there's a bunch of
cannibals it's a post-apocalyptic yeah
yeah yeah yeah so the road uh uh court
mccarthy's uh he made a book uh same guy
that wrote no country for old man and
all that corbin mccarthy and then he
made a movie with uh vigo mortensen but
it's like post-nuclear apocalypse
everyone's starving nearly everyone dies
and it's like this one guy's trying to
get his son trying to get south and they
don't really know exactly where there's
like roving hordes of you know like
warlords and like cannibals and it's
like it's horribly terrifying it was
like it's really sad just depressed i
read the book on the deployment and i
was like i just ruined this part
i like having a crappy time anyways i'm
like oh maybe i'll put a butt oh no this
is awful i've been i've been jokingly
saying that we are in
people we are in a brave new fahrenheit
1984 for vendetta
and so i'm thinking about it it feels
like all of these dystopian novels are
competing and like i wonder you know
luke you have that shirt yeah i have a
shirt about that it says you are here
and it's like the venn diagram of all of
them i have three of them and then i
have another shirt that has nine books
and movies all together
uh just to make you know the point hit
harder but yeah i mean you guys you
gotta watch fifa vendetta yeah we've
said it before but do you push the clip
about like the dude right yesterday i
was like whoa this is close
no so uh there's that so we're talking
about the southwest pilots yeah i'm
watching local news and they're like the
the airlines you know southwest airlines
cancels two dozen flights they say it
was due to air traffic control and
weather issues and then i look over at
my friends and i'm like do you guys
believe this bollocks which is like i'm
directly you know yeah quoting the line
from viva vanetta and then i'm like i
thought about it i pulled the clip where
chancellor sutler is like i want them to
remember why they need us
and then like it shows the news clips in
the first clip it says civil war in the
in the former united states is
destroying parts of the midwest and now
i'm just like oh man and then like a new
pathogen is spreading and i'm like dude
this is all happening you know outbreak
in the quarantine zone right yeah
oh that's yeah you cut it's a little too
close to home yeah and that was what
2007 ish when would that movie come out
oh man yeah maybe it's a graphic novel
originally but the graphic novel was
like was was more than just the one
story i'm pretty sure and he was like
the funny thing is the v character he
like guy fawkes was a theocrat who
wanted to blow up parliament he wasn't
like some champion of liberty or
anything he just wanted his own form of
government but but but i digress i mean
a movie about a bunch of elites
who manufacture a fake virus
then buy stock in the company that
produces the cure
use the virus to scare people into
gaining political control
and then are pumping out mass propaganda
i'm just like oh geez that's like that's
that's like all the conspiracy theorists
are probably like pointing at that and
have you guys seen utopia i'm not no
yeah so this is we've talked about this
a lot but this is the show on amazon got
cancelled because it's about a tech
billionaire who's scared of
overpopulation he tries making fake meat
it's not working so he stages a pandemic
so that everyone will get a vaccine that
sterilizes them
the show was cancelled
people were like okay
too close but like you know the weird
thing is like
do people really believe that there is a
powerful global elite tech mogul who's
trying to sterilize everybody i think
there's a lot of people who do yeah but
why cancel a show over it unless like do
do you really care about these fringe
conspiracy theorists it would still
scare enough people i think and it would
also like discourage folks i mean
whether it's true or not you know i
don't necessarily think it's necessarily
like you know some cabal like a bunch of
you know fat cat billionaires you know
sitting in a big room like this smoking
cigars trying to figure out what to do
but i think it's like very just
decentralized what if that's exactly
what it was like bill gates
there's a lot of room to believe that
powerful people do come together and you
know and and oh man
also it's kind of scary that john cusack
is a part of that movie but he's
blocking people left me yeah he blocked
me too a long time ago
powerful people
come together all the time to gain power
and make money sure it's called running
business yeah but when they get caught
doing something but when they're accused
of wrongdoing now it's a conspiracy
theory right it doesn't look do people
in government have meetings and discuss
public policy yes they do they do it all
the time
but do okay so what if what if the
policy is a bad policy that would hurt
people yeah oh that's just a conspiracy
theory i'm not advocating for any
particular conspiracy theories i think
we need hard evidence yeah
of course and i think people need to
realize that you know when it comes to
like the bill gates conspiracy theories
you don't need to look for any deeper
meaning he's literally saying it he
literally says we've got too many people
people need to have less kids you need
to stop eating meat he talks about what
what what he wants to happen and and
they write articles for it you know the
mainstream media runs articles all the
time saying stop having kids yeah fake
meat is awesome it's amazing it's like
they're doing his advertising and his pr
and what i meant to say is that one of
the biggest conspiracies is that the
government has your best interest at
heart right uh that to me is an
important slogan that a lot of people
should remember but
you know if if we see how easily it is
to buy off politicians buy off
scientists sure if we say how
multinational corporations are able to
do whatever they want it should send a
chilling effect especially when you
understand history and how it's been
welded and used uh throughout the last
few years when we have
there's uh you know one of the important
most important aspects of like fascism
for instance right and
it it comes in like national socialism
right but the whole fashion thing is
where you have major major corporations
right who cooperate for the government
for their mutually almost always at the
detriment of the people now instead we
rebranded that and those were called
public private partnerships right right
right like that's what i mean it's the
same thing they're just you know they're
putting a bow on it and you see a lot of
that right now and that's when we hear
about corporatism going you know crony
corp corporations and all that stuff
like that's the stuff that's getting
really scary and ugly and then one of
the things you point out was the russell
uh what's that one uh how basically
outside of the fan companies the big
tech companies it's like the economy if
you take away all the big super tech
companies right
yeah they're down ten percent yeah the
rest of the economy is down ten percent
but big tech's doing good yeah and so
because those those few companies are
just so massive so they're just kind of
like pulling everybody else up but like
whereas like the rest of the economy is
actually not doing so hot maybe we just
need to start referring to the democrats
and the and the establishment
republicans as the corpos just like
they're the corporate they don't it's
it's because look you know luke talks
about government not having your best
interests at heart but what if i think
if you're actually going to talk to
somebody who is not super politically
initiated they don't understand
everything that luke would be saying
yeah so their vision of government is
more like this you know young naive view
of we all come together as people and
then work for each other and help each
other and it's like in a certain point
some people realize it's a path for
power and then they start exploiting the
system so if you want to talk about the
public good i'm completely for you yeah
you know if you say hey we're all going
to band together and start a fire
department volunteer fireball i'm like
that's fantastic that's awesome you want
to talk about the government we're
usually referring to like corporate
you know style like uh well-funded
establishment corrupt individuals and
then you get the democratic
establishment and the republican
establishment and i think the only
reason the republican establishment is
doing nothing is because they know if
they go up against the trump populist
types they lose whatever power they have
and so long as they feign actually
resisting they can obstruct meanwhile
the democrat corporate you know corrupt
whatever they're just literally trying
to burn the whole thing down doesn't
john smirk say that they're like the
washington generals versus the harlem
globetrotters
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah absolutely and it was
one good friend of mine who uh he's
still active duty but he used to work as
a legislative fellow so he like worked
for a staffer and he worked in the
senate and one of the things he said
like really quickly notice he pointed
out to me he said it kind of as a joke
and he's like well maybe not really he's
like i could tell it's like there's like
a cabal between
how or between senate
republicans and house democrats right
like they're kind of you know that what
they're doing and what's interesting
even within congress itself is how and
he's not the only guy that told me about
this is how a lot of the division isn't
necessarily along party lines like
republican democrat a lot of it's so
much house and senate
you know
i'm testing our new studio we have a
coffee maker and uh
some new walking lines so i've been
bumping in front of you guys so nice but
i think coffee's a little loud to do
during the show i don't think i'm gonna
do that i don't actually think you can
hear on the mics it's just like a maybe
a little bit
maybe why are you drinking coffee at
close to 9 00 p.m
because i'm in a state of psychosis
because the media is making me not
understand what's real and what's fake i
think we're all experiencing a state of
psychosis right now
i don't i don't i don't think we are
well i looked up the definition of
psychosis and it's like when you don't
know the difference between reality and
and
fake and like what i don't have like
we're just talking about conspiracies i
don't know what's real and what's next
well but there's a difference like if
you're someone who thinks that the birds
are talking to you and you can't tell if
you're imagining it or not that's
psychosis yeah that's a dangerous thing
like i don't know whether or not this
corporation has my best interests at
heart
actually i'm sorry they typically don't
right but yeah if like if you can't tell
the difference between like rachel
maddow and news
you know maybe there's some psychosis
there i guess
that's crazy i'm kidding by the way like
if people are being kept ignorant
doesn't mean they're crazy it just means
they're being manipulated and so many
people like you know you know
guys in this room like especially you
guys it's like following the news is
your job right it's a huge part of your
job and a lot of folks are really into
and it's kind of like the passive high
but you know one of the things that and
people were in the know like you guys
are like super well known but for
there's so many folks out there where
it's like they might catch a little bit
of the news right they might catch this
but it's like they got
you know uh wives and husbands kids
mortgages jobs and it's like i don't
have time for this like a lot of folks
don't realize like it's just it's not a
huge part of their like day when i talk
to folks afterwards like oh yeah i got a
couple friends media did this this you
know they don't know what we're talking
about right half the time they really
don't i mean and you know maybe they're
going to like vote if they vote they're
going to vote just oh i grew up a
republican right we grew up a democrat
and then it backfires then yeah they
don't know who they're voting for i
think one of the things that's really
good and one of the
best benefits and i still think why
social media is like a net positive for
society as a whole and and malice has
said this so many times i think it's so
true it's like it allows
it allows the average person to call
you know our elites out on their bs
right like immediately like and very and
it was a great example it's like just
this whole thing happen with us like it
turns out like some normal guys end up
kind of breaking the story we've got
reporters calling us and also when they
say when they start putting out press
releases like oh no the fbi said it's
fine nothing happened or southwards like
no no no and if we didn't have social
media we didn't have that like nobody
would know right nobody tell and like
that's really really good despite all
the other problems of social media which
like massive flaws which are there so
that's a huge thing man just believing
these these talking heads i think that's
the one thing beaver manetta didn't have
yeah social media so people were just
watching the news like is this true
nowadays people just go on facebook and
twitter and rumble gab whatever youtube
they'll post and people can see
alternatives yeah the establishment's
trying to do it's doing everything it's
powered that hunter biden laptop thing
got that new york post story got
basically muted by twitter
i just looked up the definition of
psychosis abnormal condition of the mind
that results in difficulties determining
what is real and what is not real
i think society is experiencing
psychosis because of the amount of media
that's coming from all these different
angles whether you say this it's
dangerous no it's not dangerous it's
good for you it's bad for you yeah yeah
and their perception of reality is also
being manipulated by the social media
algorithms and a lot of the perceptions
that we see online are not the true
perceptions of our reality as well
and the voices that are talking may not
be the most important voices either or
the most you know they're conveying what
the masses feel i mean to tom's point
who has time you know as an average
hard-working american to try to find
source documents wait wait wait people
work so
for this we do for those who do yeah and
it just takes so much time to do that so
who are you going to believe and i think
that's why you know people do latch onto
conspiracy theories because they don't
trust mainstream media so what who do
they trust that's in platforms like this
maybe that's why cult worship is so
popular right now why people get so
latched on to an individual like yeah
where they'll believe whatever that i
like that guy so no matter what he says
i'm going to follow
it's the
hope principle they want some they want
some kind of hope they want to latch
onto somebody that they believe is
telling them the truth
and i mean because a lot of times i'm in
the same boat i don't necessarily know
what to believe but there are times like
this where we're talking to people we're
actually flight attendants and pilots
air traffic controllers are telling us
one thing we're seeing what's coming out
in the media we're like that does not
connect i was doing a lot of work on the
border as an example with border special
operations group and the same people who
were there when aoc went down there yeah
to visit you know on the border talking
to the sector chiefs i saw the same
videos they showed the members of
congress and it was night and day
different
and that's where i can say i know that
they're not telling the truth in this
yeah i got this tweet from matthew
iglesias he's one of the founders of vox
he said a lot of debates on here are
people who are to the left of 98 of the
public deciding that people who are to
the left of 75 of the public are huge
right wingers and it gets tiresome he
said this is an interesting poll from
last summer check this out voters are
less likely to view biden as moderate
than they were earlier this year the
ideal candidate
on a scale they say one being very
liberal seven being very conservative
and four being right in the middle the
ideal candidate is slightly to the right
wow 4.2 percent 4.2 on the scale leaning
conservative and they say trump is rated
as a 5.7 and biden is a 2.8 now for a
lot of people they'll look at biden 2.8
is closer to them
and if this is the case they'll probably
find that direction however i think if
you're paying attention to the news
you'd realize that donald trump is
actually substantially closer to
moderate and they view him far right
when he's not he's in 1994 bill clinton
right on paper yep yeah you know it's
amazing if you watch like state of the
unions and stuff like that you see like
some of the speeches you're like uh he
sounds a lot like bill clinton sounds a
lot like trump right there you know on
like immigration crime
like all this stuff is amazing i was
like it was actually really quite
stunning he's a new york liberal yeah
that's the craziest thing to me and he
ran as a conservative and i think that
that is part of what broke the
democratic party yeah all of a sudden
they had no identity but if the
republicans support helping the middle
class and you know uh you know gay
marriage
what are the democrats yeah they had
andrew yang and tulsi gabbard and like
they just ignored them it was so crazy i
think it was just because business
interests had control of the
organization with hillary clinton's you
know email scandal being if if nothing
else the shining you know red light
warning sign that something wrong was
was going on yeah and that was so much
as well like like that's one thing the
left like really latched onto was so
much of this like you know fake well
it's not completely fake but mostly fake
issues of you know all the systemic this
and the woke this the social justice
level just totally played up and because
and then when they saw that they saw
that occupy wall street you know that's
where tim that's where you you know
earned your chops where you kind of
really got started was i got what was
that that was 20 2011 10 years ago 10
yeah that was 10 years ago right and
that's where you really kind of got
started right
where like kind of got on the map is
that i mean i started doing a live
streaming coverage yeah one of the first
people to actually do live streaming and
commentary of these these big newsworthy
events and yeah the mainstream media
loved it which was huge man it was huge
and it was yeah but it was great and but
things like but it was during that time
where it's like okay we you know this
economic stuff right we're all jobs and
you know at the same time i think you
had peter schiff up you know walk down
there and he's like hey i am the one
percent he's like hey you're in the
wrong city you all need to go to dc that
was like at least the argument he made i
was there when that happened oh yeah
were you pretty interesting ian was also
down there
that was a big transitional yeah
where i met luke yeah that's so cool
yeah i knew you guys are that long
that's awesome yeah from occupy went
there with bill ottman and then we went
to the after it was like the brain trust
where there was like 50 people sitting
in a circle i was there for those okay i
didn't know you at that time but you
were there too yeah that's so crazy and
it was they were like mayor bloomberg's
we gotta take him out we gotta get him
he's a bad guy i'm like i i was like you
guys you need to use him as an ally if
you want to win this thing and they're
like
no he's a bad guy we got it and i'm like
all these zealots
it was so weird i mean you had so many
random things i mean there was events
where they people came down and gave
free haircuts to to people who needed
haircuts for free uh there was
celebrities coming down i remember rosie
o'donnell came down and she like found
me she's like hey i know you and
so many other celebrities so many other
politicians so many other people started
the conversation there and you know you
could say a lot of negative things about
it as well but but i think this was a
shock to a lot of the establishment
saying whoa whoa whoa we have obama as
president and these people are not happy
with the way that the financial systems
run with all the corruption it has
holy crap we gotta invent social justice
warriors exactly holy cow we need some
wokeness for these people so they fight
each other instead of understanding how
everyone else is screwing them over and
you guys are obviously you and everyone
else down there it's like that's kind of
where you guys you know got started in a
lot of ways right and maybe or like kind
of put yourself on the map which is huge
it's awesome by the way very successful
look at a pretty big channel back then
yeah yeah no yeah you did yeah for sure
but it was like and now it's like you
guys now like that's awesome and now but
things like the other side the enemy
class they saw that they responded and
quite frankly they responded i think
very effectively for them from their
perspective right and and i think
they've been largely successful thus far
however i think there's enough people
out there that are starting to catch on
you know a lot of folks are just like
wait wait maybe they're full of it
their psy up could only work for so long
until people realize at the end of the
day that they're getting the the the
wrong end of the stick and they're
getting screwed over even more than they
did before in 2011 yep uh but but again
the divide and conquer agenda the
wokeness i i think that has been
deliberately up played in order to get
rid of this populist energy of being
robbed i noticed one thing while we were
down there at occupy was um bank of
america across the street they were like
one all of a sudden one day they just
started doing street construction right
next to zuccotti park right it's loud
all night it would be just massive
construction so it made me realize that
the the vulnerability and centralization
of a movement you do want to hold land
to like protest but if you're going to
centralize it it's just i don't think
that's effective against the empire
right now yeah the dick like
decentralized currency seems like i'm
surprised the u.s hasn't adopted
decentralized currency yet
if they want to if they want to an arm
up on china let's go brandon
that's a lot of comments
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you